merci d'accueillir thibault veut non
merci laurent alors strasbourg
strasbourg ça paraît loin très loin
ça n'a rien à voir et souvent on me
demande souvent pourquoi je suis venu à
toulon la réponse
on m'a dit on a donné la réponse à
travers la question
on m'a dit pour la plage mady pour le
soleil mais on m'a jamais dit la vraie
réponse que comment je veux étonner
je suis venu pour la famille je suis je
suis depuis quelques mois depuis une
année
je suis parent d'un petit toulonnais
maintenant je lui fais un gros bisou et
je suis venu pour lui donc pourquoi je
vous parle de ça parce que pour moi
il n'y a pas eu de deux choix de vie ou
de l'environnement autres je me suis
simplement rapprocher de dieu bonheur
donc pour illustrer sa peau de ces
salles j'ai pris une petite citation de
voltaire je vous laisse lire en temps je
vais effectuer tous les événements sont
enchaînés dans le meilleur des mondes
possibles car la raison et la fin il a
marqué 6 si vous n'avez pas vécu tout ça
vous ne m'auriez vous ne mangez pas ici
décidera confient des pistaches ça
paraît assez assez drôle comme une
citation un peu déplacé c'est voltaire
avant la la révolution française qui a
mis en avant et qui voulait faire passer
la notion d'optimisme et de bonheur à
travers le monde a trait à la france
donc bruce et ça on va on va vivre un
petit parcours un petit parcours de vie
qui va s'adapter à chacun de vous à on
va commencer par l'éducation de chacun
l'expérience les embûches autres et on
va finir par une nouvelle vie pourquoi
je pensais cet exemple pour illustrer
pour prendre des exemples de la vie de
chacun pour aussi faire des parallèles
avec ce que j'ai vécu moi je suis un peu
jeune fait neuf ans mais j'ai vécu des
choses qui me font pouvoir parler de ça
aujourd'hui
donc on a tous une éducation différente
si demain voilà demain vous créez votre
propre boîte votre propre
marc l'autre eux
même dans la vie personnelle eux
chaque identité sera différente pourquoi
simplement parce que les valeurs et une
housse au norme qui franchit chacun pour
moi c'était très vite une organisation
de ce sport c était très vite des études
staps comme on dit pour être que sportif
et c'est là que j'ai trouvé une chienne
finitude personnel aussi donc les
différences qui périence ça peut
commencer pour pour chacun de vous avec
les premiers clients
les premiers travaux qu'ils ont réalisés
une reconnaissance 6 2 de votre de votre
évolution
et une confiance déjà portes de
financeurs autres ce qui est important
pour moi personnellement c'était une
évolution de carrière assez rapide dans
l'éducation sportive par an
et c'est cela qui m'a donné confiance en
plus pour moi j'ai pas pu créer mon
propre club sportif où j'ai coaché
président et
et c'est là qu'une nouvelle passion est
née en moi la passion de la
communication du marketing
donc voilà on passe directement aux
embûches au problème aux échecs comme
certains pourraient pour lire
pourquoi je vis à eux
parce que je commençais fois-ci par ma
propre expérience
voilà arrivés à trois quatre années de
nolwenn sport j'ai été victime dune d'un
problème
ce rêve râle parce que je faisais
américains parce que j'ai fait opérer
j'ai pas un problème
et là je vous laisse imaginer que que ne
plus pouvoir faire de sport en tant que
pratiquant pour un sportif c'est paul
plus simple c'est un peu une fille que
s'effondre mais non la oumma je me suis
dit voilà chez les agences
j'ai à nouveau j'ai une nouvelle passion
la communication marketing
c'est l'occasion de de faire les études
des personnes de personnes faisant donc
d'un côté c'est un peu prendre les
problèmes de prendre les échecs comme
une force commune d'évolution et c'est
cette chose là qui m'a aidé à rebondir
assez vite
ça peut être pour pour la vie d'une
marque d'une bosse ça peut être des
problèmes des financeurs qui part des
clients qui a perdu aussi d une faillite
une une
une rupture de d'activité mais vraiment
le but là c'est d'utiliser ces freins en
serez guillemets comme une force pour
avancer avancer avancer
là ça fait à peine six mois que je suis
est long et cette reconversion
donc ce master que j'ai passé dans la
communication a été très vite je
remercie d'ailleurs les personnes dans
la salle qui ont fait qu'en version de
travail ont été très vite récompensés à
tous c'est une mission à ses courses
mais maintenant je suis ici à toulon et
je compte faire mes preuves et encore
une fois me faire une place
appuyant terme dans et qu'un
collaborateur pourquoi je me sers tu as
su parce que dans la vie de chacun en
tant que que gérant de marco
d'entreprise vous associe par exemple
cette partie cette partie est vraiment
très intéressante parce qu'elle permet
de ne pas persévérer sur j'ai pas que
c'est mal mais persévérer mais de plutôt
se remettre en question de voir les
freins de voir les skis et des passes
qui a changé est utilisé cette ses
freins comme comme outil pour rebondir
et pour pour vivre pour vivre et penser
donc voila et enfin la dernière partie
du du parcours
c'est votre votre nouvelle activité un
nouvel édifice de chacun c'est une
partie est
on va utiliser toutes les expériences
bonnes début mauvaise après on va les
mixer et on va en ressortir grandi et on
va utiliser tout ce qu'on a pu
tout ce qu'on a pu vivre
on va utiliser pour elle l'a 20 est pour
probabilité plus fourni et plus adaptées
aux clients et pour être différent bien
aussi et pour avoir une confiance une
confiance qui évolue vers l'avant et
tout donc donc voilà le parcours on voit
on peut voir que c'est un parcours qui
avait vu qui a une fin mais à mon sens
c'est un cercle vertueux c'est à dire
que d'après ce que d'après ce que moi
j'ai dire je suis là mais non je suis là
parce que parce que le parcours
en fait c'est un éternel giclures de
recommençons et une fois arrivé à la fin
on revient au début c'est à dire que non
je suis ici ma vie ici c'est toulon je
vais vivre et différence périence j'ai
reçu des chèques mais à chacun de
rebondir vers l'avant est utilisée c'est
ses expériences bonnes comme mauvaises
pour aller de l'avant et pour et
pourrait pour évoluer
donc maintenant je vous invite à
repenser à la citation
de voltaire au début et de la été
adaptée à votre propre évolution à vous
pourquoi j'ai ça parce que c'est pas
parce que je n'ai pas encore arrivés au
problème que je n'aurais jamais il faut
y penser et c'est en s'adaptant des
dupont la 170 ici on anticipe les
problèmes par bret et qu'on se prépare
les aller vivre avec + plus de seraing
et émus affrontent et merci